aujourd'hui j'ai tout ça chez moi j'ai
trouvé un mois que ces trucs à faire
trop sol ce soit alors premièrement le
classique bon tout le monde l'a déjà
fait tu écoute la musique à fond dans
son bureau
[Musique]
à
mais des fois des gens un petit peu bête
oublié d'enlever leur casque pour mettre
la musique à fond ce qui fait qu'ils
croient que musique est à froid 3 3
[ __ ] il a dit quoi croire que la
musique est à fond haut parleurs et qui
sont en super fiesta à hollywood mais
pas du tout et là le gars tu dois
vraiment sentir qu'on mais il est tout
seul dans son entier donc ça passe sauf
si leur gamme est allumé lucas comme la
personne chez toi là tu as pas de mettre
la musique à fond soap et au bled foot
et surtout en santé que tu viens danser
comme un con devant prochaine devant moi
tout seul non n'entrons pas non bon
après évidemment être monde l'a fait
aussi tu chantes un peu fort sous la
douche bon normal
[Applaudissements]
tu peux aussi danser sous la douche oui
ça fait du bruit puisque les parois sont
relativement petites donc tu tapes
compte les comptes les po1
je n'ai pas fait j'ai jamais fait jamais
donc forcément pour pas que tes bras
tape contre les parois et que tu fasses
balle la seule possibilité de tenter
pour toi sera de lever revoir en boucle
comme ça c'est génial
deux pieds comme tu mets la radio et il
ya souvent de la pub tu attends que la
musique on démarre concernés qu'élargir
rester concentré et d'urgence c'est
génial
et la cites a vraiment pas de chance tu
vas te retaper deuxième coupure de pub
sur les radios de nos jours il yaa %
chansons et 89% pub mais cette fois tu
vas vraiment pété un câble et puis tu
vas glee s'est éclaté dans la touche
mais la personne chez toi et à perdre et
c'est toi c'est génial et remettent à
plus tard le gars lui car je suis pas
tout seul
sony fait couler sur les marchés voici
le sujet du jour est aussi des fois
quand tu es tout seul tu flippes un peu
pour rien enfin même beaucoup pour rien
qu'est ce que c'est un assassin voilà je
mourir
on voit mon que j'ai moi lecteur tu vas
me sens tout à pas comptés alors qu'il
ya juste on chez toi comme moi
précisément au dessus j'ai aussi c'est
qu'ils sont peu fou et qui font
n'importe quoi
attention ça peut être dangereux
[Musique]
et voilà c'est déjà terminé c'était mon
second podcast est sûrement mon dernier
en tout cas si toi qui regarde cette
vidéo où tu l'as bien des mets tu peux
l'aimer c'est logique ça tu peux aussi
ta boîte à machad pointe au cours de la
sortie de nouvelles vidéos
es tu peux aussi me suivre sur twitter
ou sur facebook et ça c'est dans la
description
[Musique]